pickleball is the fastest growing sport
in america surging by 40 in recent years
to nearly 5 million players the game
isn't just for pros though marcie
gonzalez of our los angeles station kcbs
hit the court with several amateur
players including former nfl quarterback
drew brees who loves the game so much
that he is now a team owner wow
dinking and doubles are probably not the
first terms that come to mind when you
think of a super bowl mvp it's dink dink
dink
but former new orleans saints
quarterback drew brees has traded the
pigskin for a paddle and is now a
pickler
how long have you been playing
really probably for about a year and a
half now but i'd say that's really
picking up now that i'm retired from
football and need a new sport to occupy
my time brees is just one of the
millions of americans caught up in
pickleball mania
anybody can play no matter what your age
or you know where you come from or your
skill set or your athletic background
the game is a mix of tennis and ping
pong played with paddles and a wiffle
ball on roughly half a tennis court
first team to score 11 points wins
it's social competitive
and accessible to pros and amateurs
alike men and women young and old i'm
working on my 88th year but i'm only 87
and i'm out here just to keep active i
just turned 65 a week ago today is my
first day and
i'm loving it so far i'm getting
exercise and enjoying the camaraderie i
can't say how many times i've gone on
the court with someone maybe in their
60s or 70s and i'm thinking to myself
okay we're about to beat these folks
pretty bad and all of a sudden they just
lack you and you're like okay i got a
little ahead of myself there
what's your favorite part of pickleball
you play with somebody and you beat them
and then after you get your phone number
and you guys are friends and like want
to play again
why do you think that it has grown in
popularity so much i think because of
the social aspect and just the
you can come out whenever you want
brees isn't just in it for fun the sport
has gotten so big that he recently
became part owner of a major league
pickleball pro team what made you decide
to get into team ownership because it's
a great opportunity to be a part of the
growth of this sport two two one owen
oversees an amateur pickleball club in
santa monica california and has been
playing for three years
[Applause]
would you say that it's really exploded
or how would you describe what you've
seen
probably exploded as a understatement
great thing great combat if governments
if businesses
if
people in their personal lives can
really absorb and live by what
pickleball is about this world would be
a great place pickleball is a different
vibe and people are really friendly and
inviting yeah
i'm hooked i'm really hooked and i would
play every day if i could
a sentiment we heard time and time again
how often do you play as much as i can
it's interfering with my job though i
will tell you that it's easy to play
pitfall sometimes it's not so easy to go
to work
it's just a lot of fun i love playing i
love watching it and i really love
competing at it though do you think
you'll be playing this the rest of your
life absolutely
for cbs mornings i'm marcy gonzalez in
los angeles
i've never played but every time i keep
hearing these stories i really want to
do it cross between ping pong and tennis
i like and the thing that gets me they
say anybody could play regardless of
your age or your skill yeah i would like
to because
it looks have you played nate no i would
like tony no it's like a mash-up sport
though right if i were ping-pong or a
tennis or badminton i'd be launching my
lawsuits
them all together yeah they today put
them all together but i love the fact
that you don't have to be uber athletic
exactly you can still go out there and
dominate yep that's
a true sport yeah we need to go play
pickleball can we do that i'll set it up
i would like to welcome
well the achilles is still screwed up
but you know i'm not i'm not gonna let
you fake your way through it all right
it comes to the courts you just guard
one spot on the court i'll take the rest
i could do that